Hey what's up it's an ask IG episode
it's been a pretty long time since I've
actually done one of these show enough
with the talking I'm just gonna start
answering some of your questions
[Music]
I mean an Afghani episode so if you're
wondering how you can get your comment
here all you have to do is leave a
comment below saying Justine please put
me in a sky 2 episode and you might see
your comment here if you don't see it
here well just keep leaving them 8 the
questions Danielle wants to know if I
ever had the chance to adopt a unicorn
what I what kind of question is that
you sure of course I would adopt a
unicorn if I could wouldn't you I went
to London where do I want to go to next
well after London I went to Norway which
is absolutely fantastic and a lot of you
guys said that I needed to come to Shh
so that I need to come to Sweden so that
is probably the next place that I might
go name three things that I can't live
without get water guy a key Xbox can't
live without him OOP Gears of War 3 or
since well it's pretty hard choice it
gave Gears of War 3 usually I love the
sims there's only so many times I can
wash my hands and go to the bathroom
favourite landmark in London huh
I'm flew the Apple store is that a
landmark no art wants to know what
happened to you Justine well uh she's
she's around here somewhere
she's probably busy doing something have
I ever considered a plank on the fine
brothers head no I haven't actually
considered that but now that you bring
it up sounds like a really good time
it's Justine my real name do have middle
name Justina is actually my real name
here's my driver's license look at that
so this Justine middle name if you
notice also my driver's license there
isn't one hey Justine who was your first
crush that's actually a really difficult
question because I basically can't even
remember what I did last weekend let
alone
my first crush obviously it didn't work
out so well what do I do on a sunny day
a rainy day well basically I do pretty
much the same thing no matter what the
weather is like outside I'll be the play
xbox or playing my computer or shoot a
video it doesn't really require any type
of specific weather Francesco and Cyn
I've ever cheated on a test I'm not
proud of this but
I have cheated in high school as I said
not proud of it but what I am proud of
is my creativity
I wrote the entire periodic table of
elements on a pop-tart and then I ate it
I didn't get caught but I do not condone
cheating you should study because the
amount of time that I wasted drawing on
that freakin pop-tart I can't study for
your test and probably I've actually
done better and not suffered a
stomachache after eating an entire
pop-tart that had marker all over it
why do I want you guys asking me
questions because this is a question and
answer show so if I don't have questions
I don't have answers and they don't have
a show yeah Amanda wants know if I like
the new Facebook layout and I love the
new timeline what do you guys think yay
nay Frankie says that he found the girl
of his dreams should I tell her you know
what actually you probably shouldn't
tell her cuz it might creep her out a
little bit especially if he just
randomly go up to a girl be like hey
you're the girl of my dreams
that's creepy maybe she'll find it
romantic maybe she'll find it sweet or
maybe she will tell you to go away get a
restraining order and never talk to you
again and if you do happen to talk to
your own you'll end up in jail because
of the restraining order and you know
what it's kind of messy take things slow
my friend Chloe wants to know have
grilled cheeses Chloe I'm not actually
sure where you're from but a grilled
cheese is basically when you take two
pieces of bread put some cheese in the
middle put them together and you grill
it
that's a grilled cheese curds asking if
I'd ever want my own web series
something like the guild for instance I
really would but I'm not actually sure
what the show would be so if you guys
have any fun webseries suggestions you
have to do that's the universal leave a
comment so you keep questions Ian is
asking if my camera what did you ask
smells like chicken or potatoes no they
smell like nothing you would smell like
anything I was only allowed to choose
one the Xbox or Siri which should I
choose that's actually an extremely easy
question I would say screw you Siri I
love my Xbox peace out girl Siri I love
my xbox more than you
noted thank you first time of the face
wants me to make a nice guy J with Siri
let's see if she wants to be in this
episode Siri how do you feel about being
in my episode of ask IJ
now you suck 140 pixie is asking how my
roommate is you just an yeah she's she's
she's good she's good
PK saying did you change your hair you
look better with blonde I did change my
hair this is more my natural color I was
giving a little sick of a blonde so
pretty much for the past year I've been
slowly going darker darker darker and
should we go what you guys think huh we
think I like it better so hopefully you
guys do too and if you don't well I'll
get used to it cuz it's my hair not
yours when I come to Georgia and have
him meet up I actually was just in
Georgia and sadly I was only there for a
day so I didn't have enough time to do a
meet up but I did get to check out the
coke museums this is that the tasted
bacteria tastes know how many o 60-plus
beverages from around the world
[Music]
how're my academic results in high
school oh boy they weren't bad they
weren't good guess that goes back to my
cheating and writing on pop-tarts notes
my take on uggs skinny jeans and
sweaters basically that's pretty much
all I wear so I'm gonna say it's the
most fashionable thing in the entire
world even if that's a lie - pretty much
everyone else don't care don't care why
am I so weird get a life huh why are you
so weird
you get a life Starbucks our coffee bean
well I don't really like Starbucks
coffee that much but coffee bean is
really really good and they have great
tea selections so I'm gonna go coffee
bean 25 cents what am I going to post
another ask IG episode hey guess what
right here here's one
fan-freaking-tastic what type of earbuds
do I use actually put them right here
they are modern warfare 3 headphones a
little earbud part actually looks like a
bullet get microphone too so I use them
when I'm talking on my phone actually I
use them when I'm gaming too so
multi-purpose how do I see myself in 15
years holy crap you know I don't even
know what I'm doing this weekend so I
cannot play in 15 years ahead
probably still making youtube videos so
yeah what's my favorite part about going
to London and Norway oh my favorite part
is meeting you guys in both of those
locations idea to meet up so I got a
chance to say hi and take pictures with
all of you she's really fun
these are awesome especially in real
life much cooler than on me wow you're
cool on the internet too but real life
is pretty sweet am i coming to Canada
Ontario anytime soon not that I'm aware
of what apps have I been using most of
my iPhone I've been using this app
called tweet bot which is a fantastic
Twitter app and there's another one
called batch which lets you easily and
quickly share tons of photos and another
cool feature is you can instantly take
pictures inside of the app and there's
no saving process
it's just instantly posted on the
Internet it's just posted it's like
freaking magic
Ariana's asking if I ever played Mario
Kart are you freaking kidding me Mario
Kart was like my childhood Mario Kart 64
was probably one of my favorite games of
all time thanks for watching this
episode of ask IJ you guys are awesome
don't forget to check out the rest of my
youtube channels and of course don't
forget to subscribe so you'll know when
I launch new videos and last but not
least don't forget to ask me questions
on Facebook on Twitter here forever
just ask them and they will get answered
at some point maybe not in the next
episode maybe no the next one
but eventually eventually I'll get to it
alright I'll see you guys later hope you
are doing amazing I love you and here's
a heart a heart for you